hey everyone let's talk about the  difference between coarse crackles  versus fine crackles so of course  crackles remember the Three L's they are  low pitch they are longer in duration  and they are loud when you compare them  to fine crackles and you can hear them  during inspiration and sometimes  expiration now what coarse crackles  reminds me of is whenever I would take a  straw as a child and I would blow air  into my drink it makes that like  bubbling noise now here's an example of  coarse crackles  oh  now with fine crackles they are higher  pitched they are shorter and they are  softer in sound when you compare them to  coarse crackles and you tend to hear  them towards the end of inspiration now  fine crackles reminds me of the light  crackling of a fire and here's an  example of fine crackles